salaries at Walmart have become insane
software Engineers for example can
expect to earn as much as half a million
dollars per year now such salaries
aren't too crazy at the big tech
companies and the VC funded startups but
Walmart isn't either of those they're a
retailer a legacy retailer for
perspective the top engineers at Target
earn over two hundred thousand dollars
less at 278 000 and at Costco the
average software engineer is barely able
to cross a hundred thousand this doesn't
just apply for software Engineers either
for product managers Walmart is offering
up to five hundred thousand dollars for
engineering managers they're offering up
to six hundred thousand dollars and even
for data scientists they're offering up
to four hundred thousand dollars in fact
Walmart is paying so much that for a
certain Tech job titles they're
literally on the leaderboard for paying
the highest compensation take solution
architect for example Walmart comes in
as the 24th highest paying company for
this position with the median of a 223
thousand dollars this place is damaged
just two thousand dollars behind Apollo
and at three thousand dollars behind
Facebook this also places them ahead of
some of the largest tech companies out
there including Cisco Salesforce Oracle
and Dell we should also note that
Walmart is the only retailer that makes
the leaderboard other than Amazon of
course but they're more of a tech
company than a retailer Walmart on the
other hand is definitely still more of a
retailer but they're leaning into Tech
more than ever in fact they have a
full-on subsidiary called a Walmart
Global Tech formerly known as Walmart
Labs with 8 000 employees why does a
retailer needed this many Tech employees
well it's because Walmart doesn't treat
Tech as an addition to their retail
business they treat Tech as the basis of
their retail business but it wasn't
always like this in fact for nearly 16
years Walmart had stalled out but since
2015 the retailer has triple their
market cap growing to evaluation of just
under 400 billion dollars making them
the 19th largest company in the world so
here's the story of how Walmart saved
their stagnating business with tech
retail giant Walmart Walmart Supercenter
the largest employer in the U.S
announcing today it's increasing the
retail giant announced plans today to
increase its minimum wage for store
employees
[Music]
taking a look back Walmart's transition
into Tech can be traced back to the late
1990s when Walmart was very much the
Boomer of the retail industry by this
point they were already the largest
retailer in the US and the world's
largest private employer in fact Walmart
still holds this title to this day with
a whopping 2.3 million employees but
while things were going great at Walmart
they were starting to see a little torn
pop pub called Amazon you may have heard
of them at first they started off as a
no-name online bookstore but every year
they were growing by hundreds if not
thousands of percent they were expanding
into new categories all the time and it
seemed like they wanted to be the
Walmart of the online World in fact they
were starting to poach a bunch of
Walmart employees by luring them with
the Sky High stock compensation this
made it easy for Amazon to steal
Walmart's world-class Logistics and
supply chain Secrets usually when an
up-and-coming competitor is able to
steal your employees and perform
extraordinarily well it's usually a sign
that they're doing something that you're
not with the case of Amazon The X Factor
was obviously their online presence so
the best idea for Walmart would have
probably been to poached some tech
employees from Amazon and a double down
on their online presence in fact this is
precisely what they've been doing over
the past several years but back in the
day Walmart would take the Boomer
approach and try to bog down Amazon by
suing them while that Fiasco was playing
out at Walmart a story jumps over to two
Tech entrepreneurs named aventi
harinarayan and Anand Raj Ramen these
guys were your classic Tech Guys from
India having both completed degrees at
IIT in India and Stanford in America
they had gone on to create an online
company called the junglee corporation
which allowed Shoppers to easily compare
prices and features of various online
products this is nothing crazy today but
back in the 1990s this was revolutionary
stuff and the Jeff Bezos would take
interest in the company in 1998 he would
buy our jungley for 1.6 million shares
of Amazon which at the time was worth
250 million dollars today it's worth 22
billion so safe to say that these two
had scored a pretty lucrative deal but
they were by no means ready to retire
both venkia and Anand would join Amazon
as high-level directors and to closely
work with the Jeff Bezos himself these
two would actually end up being an
instrumental in the launch of Amazon
Marketplace you may not be familiar with
this brand but I'm sure you know what
they do this is the part of Amazon that
allows for third-party sellers to list
products on Amazon as you know this is
basically the bread and butter of Amazon
today so it looks like Bezos definitely
got his money's worth with this Duo
while that's cool and all you're
probably wondering what in the world do
these guys have to do with Walmart well
these two are the ones that would create
what would eventually become a Walmart
Global Tech
foreign
Bezos launch Amazon Marketplace our Duo
would help him launch Amazon Mechanical
Turk this is basically the Fiverr of the
corporate world companies can Outsource
Brute Force work like data validation
and content moderation through Amazon by
the time Mechanical Turk came out though
venki and Anand had spent the better
part of a decade at Amazon and they
started to feel that it was time to move
on they didn't directly switch over to
Walmart though they would actually lean
back into entrepreneurship and start
another company together called cosmics
cosmics was a rather Niche company but
it was extremely valuable for the
Enterprise customers that were in that
Niche what did the cosmics do you ask
well they specialized in search engine
optimization more specifically they aim
to transform Vertical Search Engines
into horizontal search engines vertical
searching is the most rudimentary type
of searching it's when people enter a
keyword and the engine searches a given
database for matches horizontal
searching on the other hand is more like
the YouTube algorithm it uses the
keyword that you entered along with your
previous searches and purchases to
display the products that you would be
most likely to buy as opposed to the
products that are the closest match to
the keyword that you entered again
standard stuff nowadays but in our
concept back in the 2000s venki and
Anand would go on to build an
encyclopedia for nearly 5 million
categories with hundreds and hundreds of
parameters for example they accounted
for work customers were searching from
what course they drove what music they
listened to and even what type of cheese
they liked you could use all these
parameters to display the products that
would be the most likely to convert into
sales so for obvious reasons this
technology was extremely valuable for
retailers and they would eat it up
cosmics would end up growing hundreds of
percent per year partnering with several
organizations and even acquiring smaller
companies so cosmics was no doubt
killing it but the same could not be
said about Walmart Walmart wasn't
exactly doing bad but they weren't
exactly doing well either you see
maturity had hit Walmart like a ton of
bricks and they were feeling the pain
during the 80s and 90s Walmart had grown
a ridiculous 60x putting all other
retailers to shame but for 10 years now
Walmart had gone nowhere if the industry
as a whole had stagnated this wouldn't
be too big of a problem but e-commerce
was still growing exponentially and
Walmart was simply missing out they did
have an online presence but compared to
Amazon this was largely a joke in fact
if you navigate back to their 2010
website you're hit with a Adobe Flash
Player is no longer supported warning
Amazon on the other hand already had a
recommended section and was already
evolving into its current form Walmart
clearly needed to Pivot but if they
wanted to Stage such a large turnaround
they needed the help of experts and what
better experts to hire than the former
Amazon directors that helped launch
Amazon Marketplace and were now working
on a highly valuable search engine and
with that Walmart would acquire cosmics
for 300 million in cash in the early
2011.
and it's easy to say that Walmart just
bought their way into Tech but that's
not really the case yes they had a lot
of help from cosmics but Walmart
deserves a bunch of credit as well
usually with Acquisitions companies try
to integrate the child to company into
the parent company they want the child
company to adopt the same culture the
same philosophies the same salary bands
and so on Walmart on the other hand it
decided to take a much different
approach they could clearly tell that
what they were already doing it wasn't
working so it didn't make a whole lot of
sense to force this up and coming
company to also do the same thing
instead they would decide to adapt
Walmart to what cosmics was doing this
takes an insane amount of humility and
most companies wouldn't never make such
a pivot but Walmart did while all of
their peers were paying Legacy company
Tech salaries like atnt and IBM Walmart
was paying paying level salaries or at
least as close as they could get
obviously they would never be able to
pay as much as actual tech companies as
they simply don't don't have the same
margins but for a physical retailer they
were paying extraordinary amounts this
allowed them to recruit some of the best
talent out there including a bunch of
Amazon employees who were trying to
escape the toxic work culture at Amazon
suddenly Walmart had all the resources
they needed to build a modern online
platform and that's exactly what they
would do but they didn't just blindly
copy Amazon they did indeed add their
own twist one of the biggest bottlenecks
for Amazon is their fulfillment centers
to continue driving down delivery times
Amazon has to keep opening up
fulfillment centers that are
increasingly omnipresent I mean if you
want to deliver within 24 hours to any
address you need fulfillment centers
within 24 hours of every address that's
kind of how that works but the problem
with opening so many fulfillment centers
is that you quickly reach the point of
diminishing returns opening more centers
becomes more expensive than it's worth
but if you want to keep driving down
delivery times to 2 hours and one hour
then that's the only way but see this
isn't nearly as big of an issue for
Walmart because well they're already
omnipresent at least within the US in
fact the average American lives within
4.2 miles of a Walmart so forget one
hour delivery Walmart could do 15 minute
delivery all they had to do was convert
their thousands of stores into high-tech
warehouses and that's exactly what
they've been doing Walmart to Global
Tech could handle all of the AI and
machine learning involved in running
such a large retail operation what
products needed to be carried by which
stores and when what routes do their
trucks need to make to ensure that every
store has what they need at all times
and so on and so forth meanwhile
Walmart's Legacy business could focus on
Logistics fulfillment and customer
satisfaction this strategy was already
working out well in the late 2010s but
the pandemic changed things up big time
you see Walmart had one thing that
Amazon is still struggling to offer
fresh groceries for pickup and delivery
and this was exactly the advantage that
while aren't needed to cement themselves
as an e-commerce juggernaut
foreign
Walmart has been able to regain the
momentum that they had lost in the 2000s
over the past seven years their stock
has tripled it and their fundamentals
have led the way in fact Walmart is the
number one Revenue driver in the entire
world pulling in a crazy 600 billion
dollars per year now I do want to note
that their earnings have not kept up
with the revenue growth but this isn't
really a concern the main reason for
this is simply that Walmart has been
investing much of their profits into the
tech side of the business and the
revenue growth and for modern companies
growth is simply way more valuable than
the bottom line Amazon for example is
still not profitable but they're worth
over a trillion dollars so it looks like
Walmart has not only adopted the modern
tech but they've adapted to the modern
business landscape and that is why
Walmart is so successful to this day did
you realize how much Walmart was paying
your Tech workers comment that down
below also drop a like if you would like
to see more videos about the evolution
of companies and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically entered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one